mathieu calafiore bonjour merci d'être
en direct avec nous sur rt france alors
dans cette tribune que vous avez cosigné
vos confrères et vous même semblé être
catégorique le protocole sanitaire de
l'éducation nationale ne protège site ni
le personnel ni les élèves et leurs
familles quels sont les défauts de ce
protocole selon vous le protocole
sanitaire tel qu'il a été publié la
tient compte des données qu'on avait sur
le virus
au mois de juin début juillet il tient
pas compte de toutes les avancées qu'on
a pu faire sur la connaissance du virus
notamment l'aérosol isation la façon
dont call virus de de se diffuser un peu
l'image de la fumée de cigarette
vraiment très rapidement dans toutes les
pièces c'est pour ça qu'on recommande
nous de suivre les recommandations de
l'om est c'est à dire le port du masque
à partir de l'âge de 6 ans dans les
endroits clos pour justement éviter
d'arriver à ce qu'on a connu au mois de
mars à dire un nouveau confinement parce
que si on a une diffusion dans les
écoles dans les classes on va avoir des
contaminations un peu plus grande et
donc forcément on va avoir des parents
qui vont devoir être en arrêt de travail
des entreprises qui vont avoir moins de
salariés voir qu'ils vont devoir fermer
si le nombre de cas augmente aussi au
sein de ces entreprises et donc on
risque d'avoir économiquement des soucis
et un nouveau confinement ce qu'on veut
absolument éviter
et pour éviter ça on à la mesure tout
simple c'est de mettre le masque c'est
d'aérer le plus souvent possible
l'idéal c'est de faire classe fenêtres
et portes ouvertes pour vraiment faire
en sorte que l'air puisse être brassée
en continu et puis faire en sorte aussi
que qu'on ait un protocole bien précis
là pour l'instant il n'est pas très
précis protocole sur les zones qui
serait rouge l'avons on sait que le
virus circule énormément
qu'est ce qu'on peut faire de plus tout
ça c'est pour éviter la fameuse deuxième
vague on sait pas si elle va arriver on
sait que les indicateurs ne sont pas
bons on a l'impression que le nombre de
cas augmente
un effet boule de neige qui arrivent
mais à l'idéal ce serait de pouvoir
faire quelque chose pour arrêter ça
maintenant et ce sont des choses
vraiment tout simple c'est pas marrant
mettre le mas toute la journée je suis
bien d'accord mais si c'est si ça peut
éviter qu'on ait des personnes âgées et
fragiles qui tombe malade et qui en
meurent ce serait quand même un geste
altruiste qu'on pourrait faire
facilement mais finalement est ce que
vous direz hexyle protocole sanitaire
n'est pas corrigée dans le sens que vous
souhaitez avec les mesures qu'on vient
d'entendre la rentrée des classes est ce
qu'elle pourrait se transformer en
catalyseur de l'épidémie c'est une
possibilité
là je ne peux pas vous affirmez à coup
sûr que ça va être la catastrophe si le
protocole n'a pas changé on ne peut pas
le savoir
nous on a envie de proposer justement ça
au titre du principe de précaution on
sait comment le virus se propage
on a une mesure simple qui peut
justement éviter le nombre de cas
important qu'on risque d'avoir
maintenant est-ce que c'est sûr et
certain qu'on va avoir un nombre de cas
incroyable je peux pas vous l'affirmé
tout comme je peux pas vous dire non
plus que tout se passera bien et que
même sans les masques il y aura pas de
soucis vraiment clairement là on est
dans la protection de l'autre on n'est
pas dans la protection de soi on est
vraiment dans le geste altruiste de
protéger les autres en mettant un masque
et finalement quelles conséquences
craignez-vous pour la population pour
les services de santé si la rentrée
scolaire se fait elle qu'elle est avancé
le risque ce serait qu'on ait cette
croissance exponentielle du nombre de
cas c'est un peu vraiment à l'image
d'une boule de neige qui descendraient
duo de du pic de la montagne et puis en
descendant devient de plus en plus
grosse si on a ce nombre de cas qui
augmente et que les cas augmentent parmi
la population plus fragile plus âgées et
met en risque d'avoir de nouveau des
hospitalisations en grand nombre de
nouveaux des services de réanimation qui
vont être saturé et donc un soin apporté
à la population qui va être difficile
c'est ça qu'on craint on craint d'avoir
du mal à pouvoir soigner vraiment
correctement la population parce que je
le rappelle n'en déplaise à certains
qu'on a aucun traitement efficace
aujourd'hui pour traiter les coronavirus
alors on est à deux jours de la rentrée
est ce qu'il est encore temps pour le
ministre
de l'éducation nationale de modifier son
protocole sanitaire afin de mettre en
place les mesures de précaution
supplémentaires que vous demandez oui
bien sûr il est toujours temps on a bien
vu au moins de mai quand le protocole
est arrivé après de déconfinement
protocole est arrivé à 48 72 heures
avant la reprise de mémoire il est
toujours temps il n'est jamais trop tard
pour bien faire
donc même si on décide aujourd'hui que
le mardi les enfants de moins de 2 de
l'âge de 6 ans pardon doivent mettre des
masques
voilà on aura le temps de se retourner
on aura le temps de le faire après on
pourra discuter et ça ce sera aux
pouvoirs publics de décider ça de de la
mise à disposition de masques pour les
populations les plus défavorisées
éventuellement ça c'est pas tout ça
c'est à disputer mais on peut encore il
est encore temps de changer un peu son
fusil d'épaulé puis de de préconiser des
mesures toutes simples qui peuvent
protéger la population
alors pour conclure au docteur mathieu
calafiore on a beaucoup parlé un débattu
sur le cas des contaminations des
enfants des élèves qu'est ce qu'on sait
très concrètement aujourd'hui on sait
que les enfants qui sont symptomatiques
les enfants qui ont des signes contamine
de la même manière qu'un adulte c'est à
dire qu'ils produisent du virus et ils
peuvent le diffuser de la même manière
ce qu'on ne sait pas à l'heure actuelle
ce sont les enfants asymptomatiques les
enfants qui n'ont pas de chef qui n'ont
pas tous et ses amis qui serait porteur
du virus
e on ne sait pas trop comment ils
diffusent le virus ça c'est vraiment la
grande inconnue pour l'instant
et donc on sait que certains enfants
sont de la même manière que les adultes
des vecteurs de contamination du virus
et donc si on peut essayer d'éviter de
faire d'eux une source de propagation de
cette de ce virus de scor en à virus ça
peut être quand même quelque chose de
sympa pour eux parce que il faut pas
oublier que les enfants savent qu'ils
peuvent être potentiellement contagieux
ils le savent ils le disent à partir de
6 ans ils ont peur de contaminer leurs
proches
eh bien pourquoi ne pas leur dire si tu
as peur de ça mais ton masque et puis tu
pourras protéger tes parents tes grands
parents tes amis et les personnes plus
fragiles autour de toi merci beaucoup
mathieu calafiore d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes
directeur du d
appartement de médecine générale de la
faculté de médecine de lille et co
signataires de la tribune publiée dans
le quotidien le parisien le 29 août